hey mike what's up the sign man
you gotta get it done here we go the guy
kevin sent over is taking his sweet ass
time
i'll check on it i'll check on it
are you done yet you shoe polish
smelling mofo
it has to be authentic
can't rush these things
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up everybody so today
is the grand opening versus i say soft
opening grand opening we're hoping
it's going to be in march second week
that's what i'm hearing
but today i got a special guest on the
phone to do a virtual waltz with the
stash
because he can't be here so we're
outside we're going to start outside and
we're going to bring him inside
it's mr kevin smith
kids i'm gonna see the stash with you
all
right at the same time we're gonna
discover it together i sadly i can't be
there at this moment in time
so ernie's been kind enough to walk me
through man i can't wait to see it
all right kevin so first as you can see
we got we got the harley here
you should love that one little yoda in
front of her looks awesome
harley very good very close to my heart
uh in the old secret stash
of course uh when harley was born we put
in the front window it's a girl and
stuff so this is kind of safe
no it's good and then of course these
wonderful graphics you guys sent us
are just amazing i mean we've had
numerous amount of people come here and
stop even before we were open just
looking at the graphics i mean they love
it
good man captain rip man is our artist
on those he did the ranger danger
drawings that were in
uh jane salabab reboot uh the shirt that
jay wears all throughout the movie
captain rib man did that he did our new
sign that will be going up the new logo
that's on the
carpet when you first walk in and
whatnot and he did all those great
window clings which we're going to be
turning those into
shirts as well that people could buy
when they come because the artwork is
phenomenal
all right so what i'm going to do is
take you inside to show you how things
are going
oh look at that man walking through the
doors of the stash it's like being there
virtually
so i'm going to take it to the left side
so we got the counter
all metaled up so gorgeous man and now
is that really metal or is it like some
sort of the
applique i thought i saw you put on
there so this is a
this is a a plastic product called uh
flex lamb so it gives the appearance of
you know riveted metal and stuff like
comes in a lot of different colors it's
a really cool effect and i think
uh walter uh kind of told me it
reminded him of uh what was it i got
mike zapstick here also
so what was that that walter said it
reminded of
hey kev um he reminded of us of uh
the original iron yeah version one it's
cool though because if anybody kicks it
or dents it you can swap a panel out
with another panel and you're good to go
why are they kicking my counter
what the hell nobody's kicking mike's
got it but back here with mike
my man who's been here working really
hard we got all the uh
wall comics back here oh my god ernie
did such a great job
check that out check that out oh look at
that so that's where the wall books go
man they're
in a corner right by the right by the
front door and right by the counter
that's phenomenal and people can reach
him well well
slap their hands away don't touch yeah
don't touch we're gonna hopefully let me
touch
hopefully michael's gonna hand that to
him we got the look you can see the
little velvet rope we got right now
i see membership has its privileges
if you wanna touch you're more than
welcome to anybody else right
broken fingers but so i'm going to swing
it around as you can appreciate this
this one this is the classic the old
stache glass
ah painted by scott moser himself for
the first
iteration of the stash version one uh
that was on monmouth street in 1997.
look at that [ __ ]
i mean to this day brother this thing
looks gorgeous
i mean it's amazing that this was in
storage for so long
and then we brought it out for comic
book men in the show when i put it up
there
and then now it's in the its final
resting place of the new stash at 65
broad i mean it looks
amazing people have been taking pictures
of it all day on the opening so it's
really cool
it's a legacy piece man and you're right
it's held this far it was in storage for
over 10 years
at one point when i finally brought it
out and put it up for comic book men
right we got asmosure what type of paint
you use man because these colors pop
still
i mean i'm sure that [ __ ] is
i'm gonna swing you around to our our
merch and first we'll show you
some of the little pops we got here by
the counter we go to your jacket
and jay's jacket back together again
i know we took jays down when we started
comical is that right did it really they
took it down for comic book man
yeah yeah we needed the space yeah yeah
proudly on display once again jay's
dogma jacket
that is silent bob's hat from clerks it
is silent bob's
hoodie from clerks but that coat is the
chasing amy silent bob coat isn't that
weird
people love it taking pictures and then
right next to that is a lot of the uh
a lot of your t-shirts whole line of
t-shirts and merch over here
on the slat wall that's what pays the
rent kids
so we got all that and then we come over
here
this is the comics these are the
gondolas that were in the stash
all separated so we kind of over built
this a little bit
so we can put the comics jazz it up with
some colors put a platform on top with
the pops
the the viewers cue barrels viewer sku
productions barrel sign up there
and then check this out we got the poles
going up to the ceiling
a little batman and robin on the other
side is going to be blunt man and
chronic
coming up those are your arrows that is
phenomenal that is phenomenal man i'm so
glad that you kept the barrel
sign and i like the shelf thing that's
dope
the gondolas look new we've had those
since uh the original incarnation of the
stash
back when it was comicology uh they've
lasted this long you're talking about
gondolas that are going on
25 30 years easily yeah we we kind of
you know a lot of screw and glue and
paint put them things back together
brother
yep but we did the same thing with the
back issues as you can see look at all
this look at this beautiness
those back issue bins kids have been
with us since
we opened uh jay and [ __ ] secret stash
i believe those go as far
back as steve dave and kamikology the
original steve dave
i think they they were his first they
made the trip with us up to broad street
and now here they are
yes zapsec just confirmed that you were
right about that
and then of course let me give you over
here in the other front side we'll start
on the other side of the store
of course we've got mr tuck as you can
see
look at that and so tusk used to hang
ernie hung him on the ceiling at the
last stash
in this awesome little cage setup but
now we got him down here so people can
take pictures right next to him that's
awesome
oh yeah a lot of the kids won't go near
him but yeah but you know
they'll learn it don't learn while we're
in the front of the store let me
let me show you i don't know if you
really could appreciate the carpet
that people walk in on when they when
they come into the stash buddy look at
that
look at that man i remember when we were
talking about the carpet with zap and he
was like uh
it'll be like a couple hundred more for
multiple colors i said let's splurge
um that looks phenomenal i tell you what
my man mike
made the call on the purple it's a good
call
it's nice it's royal and also it matches
your wall over to the right
and this is the first iteration of the
stash kids i should point out
no carpets no rugs every stash we had in
jersey like that the mammoth one
and the one up on broad street had
carpets rugs look at that floor show
them that shiny floor
it's hypoallergenic nice
no coverage no coal
the social distancing things on here too
very nice and
honestly like on a day like today where
it's all snowy and shitty out
so much better to not have [ __ ] rugs
there man where they just that [ __ ]
cakes in and stuff
easier to clean at least for us up top
and all the new comics there's some new
pieces up there too we got a lot of the
classics that were have been on the
walls of the stash forever
but then i sent some new stuff that's a
piece that i was given
it was here hanging in my house forever
uh it's a piece of dogma
artwork that the entire crew and cast
signed so i figured it'd be better on
display there i also sent over
um a spirit drawing by uh the great
will eisner uh the flash and supergirl
thing i sent over
stuff that i figured would look let me
get you better in the store yeah those
pieces right there
and as well as the uh smodco the
there's the uh yes here's the smart cast
smartwatch
which can be swapped out over at uh smod
castle
well yes it can yes it can
that's the thing it's like we now have
the ability to like
shift pieces as need be or if we want to
showcase other things
because i think in the future we'll
probably be doing art shows
uh at the stash like i know shag
wants to come the guy who does the shag
painting shag himself
right um wants to come out and do a
thing so sooner or later he'll be out
there and we'll have all his pieces
hanging up including
the jay and silent bob piece that he did
and there's a forthcoming new piece that
he's doing as well
so that's another thing that we'll be
bringing to the new stash man smart
shows be fun yeah so just give me a give
me a little history
you mentioned the flash here so i'm
going to show you what you have
mentioned here this give us a little
history on that cat
so basically this piece uh that has a
you know
eagle eyes can spot the misspelling
right away i put up this picture
oh you caught it i wanted my choice all
right i've seen it
for years in the house but i put this
picture up on
on instagram and and some and i can't
tell you how many people at least five
people were like you know there's a
misspelling on that flash
right i think i think zaps is the one
that caught it first
it's uh it's a charming absolutely
charming
uh little error and stuff that adds uh
real uh
human quality to that piece and it
doesn't diminish
the sentiment with which it was given
but yes i i
so many people coming into the stash
mike
are gonna be like do you know that
thing's misspelled up there
like it'll become the new in chasing amy
like when uh ben's walk into the car you
could see the reflection of the crew
in the window and for [ __ ] 20 years
people like did you know that you can
see the reflection
of the crew in the window and ben's
going back to the car he's like yes i
[ __ ] know
this is going to be the new version of
that mic where people are going to come
up to you and be like
did you know that construction is
misspelled up there
and each and every time mike you got to
be like what
i can't believe it that thing's never
coming down
ever no my god it's a really sweet piece
man i'm glad that
folks get to see it it's been in my
house forever but it felt like it'd be
something more
at home at the secret stash yeah so of
course you know
i had to put my piece up [ __ ] yeah man
there's ernie sweat box sweatshirt as
worn by the one and only rick darris and
clerks that's actually
one of the very few clerks props that
exists
in our store the quick stop sign of
course being number one
but the sweat box like that's something
that was in the [ __ ] movie was that
the same one you wore in the movie or a
duplicate
oh no that's that's that's it you you
you
you told me you said i need that
sweatshirt
yeah we don't i think about it dude
there's not a lot of props from clerks
like
we just like clerks existed in that
store
so most of the props belong to quick
stop and stuff so like
having that is a true touchstone to our
beginnings the whole idea of the secret
stash
when we got it the first time around we
just inherited a comixology
but when we moved it up to broad street
the idea was
let's make our version of planet
hollywood that's a
dated reference that no kid in the world
is going to understand today
but kids planet hollywood was a
restaurant where they put props from
movies on display all different movies
so the idea of the stash was let's put
up our
own props and whatnot and right there
that's framed
sweat box sweatshirt is literally a prop
from clerks one could argue it's costume
but
either way it's directly from the set of
clerks it was there
when we were there just like that quick
stop sign but with that said
we are going to spin you around and show
you the shrine of mr buddy
the new the new shrine of mr buddy
so let me give you a little taste bud
oh my god it's just like being in church
it's like going to olph again where me
and ernie went to school
and wore uniforms look at that and for
the first time ever
buddy is not behind glass and look at
that
kneeler that kneeler man i remember when
ernie
showed me that kneeler on ebay
marketplace or whatever and was just
like
look at this man facebook marketplace he
was like look at this
we could get this kneeler if we order it
now from rhode island
and somebody went and picked it up from
rhode island yeah our man uh our man
chuck
chuck took it down for us yeah so he
hooked this up
and then we got a pew also that was
donated by ross brewing now what ross
brewing is doing with a pew and her
brewery i have no clue
but wait let's see the pew look at that
man how tremendous so they can literally
either
kneel or just sit and contemplate
like in church the cross carved in the
side
oh god that's nice look at that [ __ ] man
that's
i that's that's a classy piece of the
store right there man
like really close well done man and the
stained glass [ __ ] looks fantastic now
that's
i've mentioned that in the video is that
that stained glass this
was repurposed from the original store
that was here
oh from the doors yes from the doors
that's [ __ ] dope man
how awesome is that yeah so instead of
throwing them out we kind of cleaned
them up
you know they're a little uh it's you
know a little raggy but they look great
they got a lot of character and the
light shining through it just is
is just amazing it just looks like this
is exactly what it's supposed to read
like church man that's tremendous
and right on top is the blunt mobile is
that correct yeah so i'm gonna back up a
little bit for you
and i got you and jay
very very cool so cool
and like that's i can't believe we've
managed to hold on to that
for as long as we have and you put it up
on that
platform in the last stash man which
afforded us a lot of space but that
looks great coming out the ceiling very
wow yeah it looks it looks dope and then
behind us
no not playing in hollywood very hard
rock cafe
yes yes that's what we thought yes and
then behind you is that we put the brody
sign back
up with a nice comic display underneath
it and look at how huge that is man
wow that's amazing that looks great yeah
it really looks great
and the wall colors look great i should
point out for the record that the
one side is blunt man colors the other
side is chronic colors
yep the whole the whole store is
basically blunt man and chronic
colors uh with a little bit of movies
kind of thrown in there but the majority
of it's based on blonde mandy chronic
i love it the old incarnations of the
stash
were red and blue like in honor of
superman and some yellow
but we've now been around long enough
where we can reference our own
superheroes
it's true and we got of course the
wonderful cases here
with some more memorabilia from a lot of
your films
yeah that's all the the very tiny and
walk away props we keep beyond glass
the grappling gun as the original head
of the golgothan that vic
vince guastini gave me that can is held
by betty aberlin
in uh the opening of dogma um that
that card uh you know came as a
celebratory card for goodwill hunting
um and me and scott have the framed like
credit to the left there
oh that'll be the backpack of course has
from jane salam bob's strike back the
diamonds as well
swallow my cacaccino the slate from
uh zack and miri the star horse script
as well as the slate the uh
pitchfork from jay and son bob strike
back as well as the harp from jane salam
bob's strike back
sweet and sour surly and egg and movie
muffin all that [ __ ]
i believe the bag and that like
i'm not sure yeah it's clerks too i
think that's when we made the sweet and
sour surly might have been for dogma as
well
um but those becky's glasses i imagine
sitting right there
yep and then this is the last one up top
a little bit more movies
stuff back there and little pieces of my
[ __ ] uh
childhood look at that [ __ ] that's
awesome yeah
so then on the other side of this next
to buddy
the beautiful display cases that mike
zapski put together i mean these things
are
just incredible i mean this is people
just
they're great to look at but i'll tell
you we they they got to come buy it i
mean it looks so good the showcases so
all the sculptures and whatnot the
sculptures and just all the
the statues and you know i hate to say
dolls but there are you know
in the star wars stuff there's a lot of
vintage things in here
um you got to check it out okay look at
this
oh that's gorgeous oh and look at that
big old superman sculpture a lot of uh
collectible stuff like in the in the
window
the harley quinn the yoda that's from
sideshow collectibles they make the best
stuff those
the uh iron bob sculpture and the helmet
that's from
um bob kurtzman himself so we sell those
uh that uh hulk bust of course is from
sideshow and look at that original
artwork over uh over
this that's joe casada and jimmy
piamiati doing the mall rats opening
credit artwork with their character ash
and i see some nice space so we could
still hang some [ __ ]
we left a little bit a little bit of
things up and then this is a great piece
i know that yeah
check that out yeah look at that
daredevil piece kids
that's joe casada artwork right there
from the last
page if i forget what issue it was maybe
three or four of our daredevil run
and originals yeah and then of course
next to that i was gonna slide you over
to we've had more comments today
and what the wow factor of this piece in
the stash
all right mike i mean oh my god yes it's
just been
unbelievable i mean let me show you how
it looks
oh he looks phenomenal god he looks
great ernie had the idea early on
about having iron bob bust through the
wall and i said oh my god yeah that'd be
dope
and look at man he [ __ ] pulled it off
he got the chest light lit up as well
that's tremendous
yeah he looks good man otherwise he'd be
just sitting in a storage
container bob kurtzman's place so so
nice
that he gets to be on display that's the
original costume kids
i never wore it not once i called you a
couple weeks ago
and i said kev you're sending me the
iron bob oh yeah i'm going to send you
to iron bob
i said all right is this the stunt
costume is this the second or third
costume
and you're like no ern this is the only
one
they only made one we didn't have that
kind of budget for multiples man
i don't you know i was nervous as [ __ ]
well you did a great job with it and
it's forever enshrined right there
the uh the the um guy who wore it in the
movie
i put up on my instagram back when the
movie came out his name's kevin too
he was in iron man the original iron man
as the kid who's in the humvee with
tony stark when he's like uh no gang
signs
he's like go ahead you throw up gang
signs peace yeah i love peace like
that kid who then gets shot he was the
guy wearing the iron bob suit and jane
sound bob reboot so he was like i have
come full circle
like now i'm iron man i'm like close
iron bob it's
it's pretty bad ass i was very very
tempted
to put it on yes but i i i didn't want
to put any
juju on it i think i think
you did such an amazing job of the story
you would have been entitled to [ __ ]
put it on
naked dance under the moonlight and [ __ ]
you know how you know how i do i would
have stuck to that song [ __ ] inside i
couldn't would have been able to get out
that's beautiful man that setup is so
[ __ ] nice well
very dramatic [ __ ] what a great uh
place to take a picture he's got him
right over your shoulder
that's tremendous oh yeah and then of
course the uh
the most wonderful thing in this store
something that hasn't seen the light of
day well it has seen
the light of day but hasn't been
properly lit
since it made it to the stash on 35
is the quick stop now i'm going to show
you the quick stop
facade it is 95 done
so you can appreciate it i'm still going
to do um
the entrance into the store and
i know i'm going to rough it up a little
bit so it looks kind of
kind of shitty well i'm going to weather
it a little bit
but just to give you the effect with
with everything on it and
not to mention when you come back here
to take your photos
there is going to be uh i'm waiting for
somebody to send me a timeline
for the for the back of the st of the
stash
uh we're gonna have a team that's me i'm
responsible for that i'm still working
on it
okay so the timeline is gonna be
underneath the tv we have that's gonna
be running clerks
clerks two jay and simon bob strike back
reboot things like that to be on the tv
uh so check this out kevin i mean it's
just amazing
god damn it man you did such a good job
that's tremendous and look at the sign
he's right that hasn't been lit up like
that since it lived at quick stop when
we kind of put it at the secret stash
we weren't like let's light it up we
were just happy to have the signer and
he framed it but now
it's uh when ernie was talking about
building
the facade of the quick stop in the back
he was like the centerpiece is the quick
stop sign like we legitimately have the
quick stop sign
that looks phenomenal man and it's so i
mean it's
we went we weren't true to form brother
it's it's
it's real steel all real it's not
none of that plastic and paint
nice people people should love this what
are you gonna do for the door
uh i am gonna make a wooden i'm gonna
make it out of wood because doing it out
of aluminum
framework is just way too expensive so
you're going to make a door that
actually opens
you up no no no we can't not but i mean
a facade of a door
a side of a door with a side light just
like it is at the quick stop and then
what i'm going to do is i'm going to add
a a
a photo in back of the glass that looks
like the inside of the quick stop
so if you're looking through the glass
it looks like you're looking into the
quick start brother
that's [ __ ] dope
so what we're going to end with here
today i'm not going to take you down
into the basement you know
everybody knows what that looks like
they've seen that in the videos but the
last thing we got
is the tell them steve j general store
general store man let's see let me see
the exterior so
this will be the exterior
but you're gonna have to gonna have to
appreciate the
the sign i don't think can you get that
kev let me see louise
oh my god the signs adorable testy town
general store
that's [ __ ] dope man look i mean look
at the
look at the artwork on that i mean it's
the detail is just incredible i mean
it's wonderful who did it anybody know i
know that's the you know their cartoon
artwork from some of this
zap do you know who did that sign for
walt not a clue no
to be honest it's beautiful it's
beautiful there's a store within a store
kids what we can do is get a credit and
drop it on the video when we when we let
it go
but tell them steve dave so here he goes
the counter when you walk in
oh [ __ ] so that's a piece of the old
counter from the secret stats yeah this
was actual comic book men
used screen used counter that we
repurposed
uh for the tell them steve day room walt
wanted it in here
and i said no problem dude we'll hook
you up
that's phenomenal let me see the hats
they got collection yeah yeah
he's got some hats in here that he's
selling he's got some great artwork up
here
you know oh that's phenomenal all the
artwork and then there's their big ant
head
all the artwork that we had of the boys
around the old store
is now concentrated in the testy town
general store which is very very sweet
let me see there
you gotta see the case man look at the
case
oh my god this is one of the things i
always enjoyed
when i went back to the stash is how
much crap
they collected for their podcasts like
how many creative people
gave them things how many things came
from the mythology of their podcast
the puppets people doing action figures
there's a [ __ ] get em figure for
heaven's sakes
seeing all that stuff like always did it
for me
in such a big bad way there you go
here's their other wall with their
photos and shirts and stuff that they're
they're selling to their fans and
posters and there's that piece of
artwork too from frankenstein meets the
oh is there one of those shirts yeah
these are the shirts
that is so cool let me see their
stickers let me the cards they put on
little laminated cards and [ __ ] that is
dope
yeah oh my god
it's so awesome i love look at that
my boy's got a mercantile instinct just
like me
this great poster what is that is that a
poster
it's a flock poster kevin yeah mike just
said they call it a flock
poster a flock
yeah like remember the 3d posters we we
we used to get from uh the black light
yeah is that one of them it's velvet
it's perfect
that is dope yeah it's cool as hell
isn't it
that is [ __ ] crazy that's wonderful
man
and then of course you know they got the
baron
the outfit on display that is so [ __ ]
dope yeah
and they got these great chairs for
their podcast
the cue honest still with the same
[ __ ] uh
poker table how awesome yeah
but never getting rid of it how much
green wall they have is it one whole
green wall
uh yeah i mean i'm gonna say we're
probably looking at a good uh
yeah you could shoot in corners and
stuff that's good yeah yeah they got at
least 16
almost 16 feet do they have room
uh in that on their walls i know one
wall is all sales stuff and whatnot do
they have yeah there's some space over
there
over that shelf there i'm gonna send out
some comic book men
framed stuff that i got that okay
that'll look good there because it looks
like they're putting up some stuff
that's not just testy right like comic
book men's part of it
oh yeah i mean there's a little bit of
everything here yeah
i mean yeah i'm gonna send those pieces
out i got really nice framed artwork
from like the promotional
artwork that they did for the show so
they can it'll look good back there too
we'll look out for that
but i mean that's pretty much the store
the back is every just you know
where our storage is and all that kind
of stuff which we showed in the videos
but
all in all brother that is the store you
did an excellent [ __ ] job man look at
that [ __ ]
oh my god well done my friend i remember
when we first started talking about this
and there it is there she blows mike how
do you feel
feels like we're home
feels like worse is it more spacious it
feels like it
is uh the old store we were so cramped
and we had like weird angles now
we're right here nice
it looks phenomenal um the idea kids is
that uh me and jay are gonna be there
uh march 13th and 14th
for grand opening weekend and when we're
building it right now
it'll be a reservation system so that
people aren't standing outside in the
cold and like you know
a bunch of people don't show up at once
you'll get a time and that way you'll
know
the window to show up around and stuff
like that but uh
i'll be there very very soon i thank
ernie and
and mike and christian for virtually
touring me
through it man um it's it's gorgeous
erin you did a great job like
for those that don't follow that closely
the very first secret stash
uh we you know we just kind of took over
and walt and bry repainted the walls and
we opened
um the second c scott of course painted
the front window but that was that
the second secret stash when we moved up
to broad street
uh rat face robert holtzman who was our
production designer on
uh chasing amy dogma jay and silent bob
strike back
uh jersey girl clerks ii and zach and
miri make a porno
uh him and his crew did the inside of
the stash painted the walls put
everything together built like the fake
skyline outside the old windows before
that got replaced by the old stash
window and stuff
but this secret stash has been ernie's
and ernie's alone from the ground up man
what you see
is reflected of his tastes and what he
wanted to see
in the store as not just somebody who
likes this [ __ ] but somebody who was
in this [ __ ] as well so i can't thank
you enough man you built this a new
goddamn home and it's a temple
literally a temple at one point there's
a kneeler and a [ __ ] pew
but you know i wouldn't do it for
anybody else buddy you know that thank
you my friend and he did it for free
kids that's right this guy works for
free
you did a great [ __ ] job look at that
i can't wait to be there and and take
pictures of people
march 13th 14th kids uh we're gonna have
ourselves grand opening man
well thank you brother we had a great
team behind us and everybody
pitched in to get this place together
today so uh
you got it you got a great staff here
pal many thanks uh
to mike to johnny to taylor
to carol of course to ernie and ernie's
crew who'd you bring in wayne who's
my buddy wayne in uh i brought my buddy
uh troy came in for a little bit my
nephew brian came in for a little bit
uh yeah i mean whenever i needed
somebody they were here um
that was great i mean get him help here
and there when i needed him
it was everybody was hands on i mean it
was uh it was good
it was it was good we had our ups and
downs and
some troubles here and there with uh the
weather and the town and stuff
but you know we persevered and made it
through and you know we wanted to get
open
and of course uh most importantly how's
walt like it
well mike he seems to like it a lot
yeah he he liked he had i'll tell you
what he had a good time with all the
people today
yeah yeah
absolutely oh yeah yeah yeah they were
all throughout this whole place
they were here they were there they were
buying tons of stuff it was it was a
good day it's just the beginning brother
congratulations kids thank you so much
boys for putting this together man we
got a new home everybody go to
jane sambab secret stash 65
broad street merely 30 addresses down
30 numbers down from the old secret
stash
we're open right now and then we're
having our grand opening
march 13th and 14th all right brother
thanks for everything you know we got to
get back to work and start stocking the
shelves again
so we'll open up tomorrow all right pal
thank you man thank you so much i love
you you're fast
thanks pal i'll see you all right that's
it that's from the boss the boss loves
it the boss is uh
he wants you to come to the secret stash
and check stuff out so i'll come down
and see mr mike zapsic
what the hell is this we've gotta go
stock i've gotta
mike stock falls apart he's to call me
anyway so
so ernie thank you for building us home
you got it though my
mommy i love you
thank you good luck you too right now
peace out check us out
[Music]
you